heute ist es soweit die mars sonde
insight wird auf dem roten planeten
landen dabei gelangen die letzte
erfolgreiche landung auf dem mars 2012
sechs jahre später soll es endlich
wieder einen erfolgreichen touchdown
geben erst 2016
kräfte der mars länder japan rallye
ungebremst mit 5 140 stundenkilometern
auf die marsoberfläche heute soll ab 20
47 alles glattgehen klicks um
science-fiction
hier gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
das war wirklich eine absolute
katastrophe für die raumfahrt am 19
oktober 2016 eine fehlfunktion des
bordcomputers führte zum absturz von
scapa rally der länder sollte alle
funktionen einer landung der exomars
mission der esa der europäischen
weltraumagentur testen dieser test
mißlang nach allen regeln der kunst
statt einer höhe von 3,7 kilometern
ermittelte der bordcomputer - zwei
kilometer öffnete die bremsfallschirme
zu früh und sprengte das hitzeschild ab
der mars länder tabarelli donnerte mit
540 kilometern pro stunde auf den mars
boden totalschaden
die exomars mission ist eine der
wichtigsten mission der europäischen
weltraumagentur esa
trotz dieses versuches wurden dann auch
die mittel für die fortsetzung der
exomars mission freigegeben denn die esa
möchten die chance nicht verpassen
vielleicht die erste
weltraumorganisation zu sein die
außerirdisches leben oder zumindest
früheres außerirdisches leben im weltall
nachweisen kann dafür wurde die exomars
mission speziell entwickelt sie wird
einmalige möglichkeiten bieten und zum
ersten mal bis zu zwei meter in die
tiefe des mars bohren können um dort
leben aufzuspüren und gibt es dort noch
leben sind die chancen dort am größten
ist unter der oberfläche mit einer
probebohrung dieser art aufzuspüren aber
jetzt soll sich erstmal die mars sonde
insight in den mars boden graben sie
soll ein besonders tiefes loch bohren um
den geologischen aufbau das maß zu
untersuchen
bis zu fünf meter tief soll das loch
werden die tiefste bohrung der
menschheit auf einem fremden platz
überhaupt im bohrloch wird dann der
burghof erwärmt und es wird gemessen wie
sich die wärme im boden verteilt daraus
können sehr detaillierte erkenntnisse
über den aufbau des mars gewonnen werden
dieses sieht flow and physical
properties package instruments ti wurde
im deutschen zentrum für luft- und
raumfahrt dlr in berlin adlershof
entwickelt und gebaut zusätzlich gibt es
noch ein seismometer der französischen
raumfahrtagentur cmbs hiermit sollen
erdbeben und weitere innere aktivitäten
auf dem maß gemessen werden und somit
weitere erkenntnisse über seine struktur
gewonnen werden aber jetzt geht es
erstmal darum ob die sonne überhaupt
heiler auf dem mars boden ankommt um 20
47 trifft sie auf die dünne mars
atmosphäre und erhitzt sich dabei auf
1500 grad celsius ein hitzeschild
verhindert dass die sonne dabei vergnügt
durch die starke reibung wird die sonde
abgebremst und zwölf kilometer über dem
boden öffnen sich dann die
bremsfallschirme ganz zum schluss zünden
kurz die brems triebwerke und insight
landet hoffentlich sanft auf der maas
ebene elysium planie ca wenn alles gut
geht aber nach dem crash 2016 ist das
mission steam verunsichert deswegen
heißt es heute am 26 november 2008 10 7
minuten hoffen und bangen denn so lange
dauert die landung bei uns erfahrt ihr
natürlich über whatsapp ob alles
geklappt hat damit ihr dort nichts
verpasst einfach hier draufklicken da
bekommt der unsere videos auch vor allen
anderen und auf dem englischen kanal
geht es weiter mit diesem thema exciting
discovery monster galaxy s most of the
milky way einfach draufklicken hier und
am besten abonnieren also ich hoffe wir
sehen uns auf dem englischen kanal denn
da gibt es auch spannende videopremieren
also stay tuned